[Musique]
bonjour excellent mais bonjour nous
commençons par ce message de fermeté que
veut adresser en tout cas le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson à
l'égard des migrants oui le royaume uni
a annoncé hier la signature d'un accord
avec le rwanda pour y envoyer ces
demandeurs d'asile arrivés illégalement
un aller simple pour le rwanda où elle
ytc est ce titre le quotidien
conservateur a le daily mail bourhis il
appelle boris a regardé boris injure que
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
iront en afrique et le premier vol
pourrait avoir lieu avant la fin du mois
prochain donc avant la fin du mois de
mai perception vous allez le voir
différentes 1 du côté du guardian
quotidien la ligne éditoriale est bien
plus social le plan des demandeurs
d'asile au rwanda qualifié d' inhumain
des politiciens les experts juridiques
et des groupes de réfugiés condamne le
projet de johnson l'homme dit abhorrer
sont ni johnson de délocaliser la crise
de la traversée de la manche cet accord
intervient avant les élections
municipales du 5 mai en angleterre et en
écosse et ce c'est ce qu'illustre ce
dessin du times avec une caricature de
la très droitière priti patel la
ministre de l'intérieur avec qui appelle
au vote et puis devant moi le fera
ministre boris johnson au premier plan
scène mais grandstand a envoyé les
migrants au rwanda la guerre en ukraine
à la une du figaro ce matin cinquante
jours de combats les visages de la
guerre 50 jours d'enfer divisé avant
l'offensive russe lancé le 24 février
c'est une nation qui s'est forgé dans la
lutte pour sa survie les ukrainiens
résiste chacun à leur façon aux assauts
et bombardements meurtriers de l'ennemi
et l'on voit donc ses différents visages
qui illustre selon le figaro la guerre
actuellement en cours entre la russie et
l'ukraine et puis toujours 7
hier avec ce dessin paru dans la presse
britannique qui illustre là aussi ce
croiseur ce navire amiral russe de la
flotte de la mer noire qui a sombré et
qui continue à faire couler sans jeu de
mots beaucoup d'encre avec vous le voyez
le visage de poutine illustrant ce
navire avarie 1 selon le kremlin
conséquence d'un tir de missile selon
l'armée ukrainienne se caricature irrité
a dit qu'il ya a pris l'option du tir de
deux missiles et puis cette une qui
interpelle à la une de la stampa la
presse et italiennes on parle souvent du
sort des mineurs la bambine hyper
d'outils les enfants perdus de la guerre
avec cette photo ce bébé dans une
poussette
encore une fois qui interpelle et ne
peut laisser insensible
la présidentielle française on nous
parlait ce matin non pas des deux
candidats encore en lice pour le second
tour mais plutôt de ceux qui ont été
battus oui alors j'en ai choisi de aussi
parmi les dix qui ont été battus d'abord
enfin c'est plutôt la presse qui a
choisi pour moi la une de libération 22%
et qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
s'interroge le journal tendance
socialiste fort de son score au premier
tour la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon
représentant de la france insoumise elle
tient le sort de la gauche entre ses
mains en vue des législatives qui auront
lieu juste après les présidences de la
présidentielle et en vue d' un début de
reconstruction la gauche a qu'un carnet
dans le monde d'avant le parti
socialiste est justement la candidate
socialiste à la présidentielle
1,75 pour cent des voix a fait son
retour dans la capitale puisque anne
hidalgo est également maire de la ville
à 62 ans il lui reste quatre années à
diriger la ville de paris où un procès
en illégitimité
l'attend et oui lorsque vous avez fait 1
75% la présidentielle difficile ensuite
de se faire de faire preuve d'autorité
politique dans la capitale
autre chose les pages people des
quotidiens s'en donnent à coeur joie le
prince harry a revu sa grand-mère et oui
le prince harry le prince rebelle partie
avec la roturière américaine
megan merkel est allé discrètement
rendre visite à la reine c'est par
exemple une du daily telegraph aux
photos d'archivés les à sussex ont vu la
reine et le prince charles pour la
première fois depuis qu'ils se sont
retirés de leurs fonctions royal précise
le daily telegraph ils sont ensuite
partis puisqu'ils habitent aux états
unis pour les invictus games et oui
c'est le but principal de revisite ce
sont ces jeux dédiés aux blessés de
guerre notamment fondé par le prince
harry c'est la cinquième édition ça se
passe à la haye aux pays bas c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi adéens celle d'acs
bague journal
des pays bas et l'on voit le chef de
file de la délégation hollandaise à qui
il manque une jambe depuis cet ancien
militaire depuis
1994 il avait le dénommé el wild wolf
sauté sur une mine terrestre lors d'une
mission à c bre srebrenica et il
explique effectivement que ça aide à se
reconstruire le sport pour tous ces
personnes handicapées tous ces
militaires qui ont été blessés soit au
combat soit à l'entraînement merci
beaucoup axel mais c'était la rof